I'm little bit hesitant to overstate the
risk because some science is risk in
some science is not I do think that
probably biological advances will entail
ethical considers and I don't mean that
we shouldn't be doing certain types of
research but I mean we should be able to
evaluate for example if we do understand
genes how much do we want to be able to
engineer I mean there's I don't know
that that's a risk but I think it's
important to be able that there's a
systematic way of asking these questions
and that they're on the table there
probably are risks to the environment
there probably are risks to our food
supply and it's not necessary from
science but sort of how science a it's
implied in sort of more agricultural
industrial context there probably are
risks associated with antibiotic
resistant bacteria there risks that sort
but a lot of the risks I think have to
do with saying how things are applied in
general and I think that has I mean it's
not just a science research to be
controlled but perhaps industries using
scientific advances should be better
controlled for example um you know bio
engineered food it's not that it's
necessary bad but there should be some
way of regulating it to see if it is bad
or not and right now it's not I mean so
I think the risks are sort of that
things are changing so fast that sort of
regulation doesn't necessarily keep up
with it so that's probably more than